madame monsieur bonsoir heureux et ému
et impatient de retrouver l'équipe de
france zinedine zidane a exposé ce matin
les raisons de son retour
pour lui les pressions sportives et
économiques ne sont pas ses principales
motivations gros incendie ce soir sur la
commune d'aubagne dans les bouches du
rhône 500 sapeurs pompiers sont
mobilisés cinq d'entre eux ont été
blessés
le trafic sncf entre marseille et nice
est interrompue quinze mille foyers de
la ciotat sont privés d'électricité
deux jours après l'accident de l'airbus
d'air france à toronto les enquêteurs
canadiens semblent mettre hors de cause
la procédure d'atterrissage de
l'appareil
il faudra attendre l'étude des boîtes
noires pour en savoir plus
pour l'instant le pilote de l'avion n'a
pas pu être interrogé il est toujours
hospitalisé pour une blessure au dos
alerte maximale à londres comme chaque
jeudi après les attentats du 7 et du 21
juillet dernier
c'est dans ce contexte que le numéro
deux d'al-qaïda a menacé dans une vidéo
la grande bretagne et les etats unis
nous décrypterons ensemble cet
enregistrement
enfin nous serons aux côtés des
gendarmes de haute montagne de chamonix
chaque jour été comme hiver ils
interviennent pour secourir les
alpinistes
son intervention était très très
attendue par le monde du football
zinédine zidane s'est expliqué ce matin
sur les raisons qui l'ont poussé à
revenir en équipe de france
zidane qui se dit émue impatient et
heureux de retrouver le maillot bleu
pour faire je cite le maximum avec les
copains on les écoute moi en tous les
cas ce que ce qui est très important
dans tout cela c'est que c'est que j'ai
la bénédiction de mes parents et c'est
la chose la plus important reste le
reste c'est c'est c'est après sur le
terrain que ça se passera quoi
aujourd'hui je suis
je suis content serait et puis surtout
aussi content d'être ici en préparation
et il me dire que dans 15 jours je veux
retrouver les copains les bleus quoi
zinédine zidane qui refuse l'étiquette
de zorro mais du côté des supporters il
est attendu comme un sauveur pour
qualifier la france en vue de la coupe
du monde 2006 réactions recueillies à
marseille par yannick à rossi et michel
comme à marseille face à la mer zinedine
zidane est depuis quelques années une
tête d'affiché des touristes viennent
même de normandie pour ce qui est
presque devenu un pèlerinage à nos
vacances et bah vous diront ici à
marseille pour voir va le mur de zidane
et puis là pour le fou à l'équipe de
france sans idan n'était pas l'équipe de
france et la cité de la castellane sans
zidane ce ne serait pas tout à fait la
cité de la caste et notre enfant
c'est formidable voilà le petit yazid
comme on l'appelle ici a fait ses armes
de footballeurs sur cette place alors à
la castellane la victoire de l'om hier
soir en coupe intertoto passe au second
plan
la nouvelle qui compte c'est le retour
vous y joue une équipe de france
personne n'a fait ça de remettre sa
décision nuit l'a fait c'est que
vraiment il va me rapporter bien ça me
fait trop plaisir c'est merveilleux
qu'est ce qu'on peut espérer de mieux
que ça il manque maintenant on est
content pas qu'elle arrivait pas ce que
ça va faire du bien zidane en équipe
nationale c'est l'expérience un sens du
placement hors du commun et pour son
coéquipier fabien barthez c'est aussi
une arme psychologique comme ça on se
remonte un peu plus veut dire et puis
bon pour les équipes adverses aussi
savoir qui réside en face avec un mac à
l'hélice et 5 et à tous les schémas
commence à changer
la balle est donc dans le camp des bleus
qui pour satisfaire leurs supporters
devront se qualifier pour la coupe du
monde
que s'est il passé en coulisses pour que
zinedine zidane décide finalement de
revenir en équipe de france il l'a dit
dans son intervention de ce matin cette
décision était mûrement réfléchi pendant
ses vacances
bien sûr il ya les motivations
personnelles du champion mais aussi des
sollicitations extérieures décryptage
avec romain messi
il y un an il tournait le dos aux bleus
une décision irrévocable
pourquoi alors un tel revirement le
dialogue n'a jamais été simple avec
raymond domenech
mais il est dj dan a finalement été
convaincu par les relances du
sélectionneur un domenech qui se dit
particulièrement heureux de son retour
les instances du foot français ont tout
fait pour faire revenir zidane
même s'ils s'en défendent et garde le
secret qu une pression il ya rien il ya
eu simplement des gens qui ont discuté
et un amour du maillot nam mon équipe de
france qui l'a emporté et c'est pour ça
que je suis sélectionneur fédération
supporters c'est tout le football
français qui est soulagé du retour de
zizou
oui zidane leur a tellement manqué ce
matin les réactions de ses sponsors sont
immédiates meilleur produit d'appel pour
les publicitaires zidane manquait aussi
aux marques avec lesquelles il est sous
contrat idan est un énorme ambassadeur
de la marque et et c'est c'est forcément
une bonne chose qu'il rejoue sous le
maillot de l'équipe de france pour le
marché français
zidane est parti mais zidane à des bleus
à l'âme peu à peu le doute s'installe le
1er avril déjà les médias anticipe
l'annoncé de son retour sur la base de
quelques confidences
zidane dément jusqu'à hier depuis le
mois de janvier
il s'interrogeait et ils avaient envie
de jouer en irlande il avait confié il
avait envie
de jouer les qualifications pour la
coupe du monde surtout l'équipe de
france inquiète son monde depuis un an
et zidane avec il revient pour qualifier
les bleus pour la coupe du monde en
fâcheuse posture dans leur groupe
éliminatoire mais zidane n'arrive pas
tout seul
makelele et thuram devraient lui
emboîter le pas les champions de 98 à la
rescousse
je vous le disais en titre 500 sapeurs
pompiers combattent actuellement deux
incendies sur la commune d'aubagne dans
les bouches du rhône
cinq d'entre eux ont été blessées ces
incendies ont entraîné une coupure du
trafic sncf entre marseille et nice et
deux lignes à très haute tension ont été
endommagés privant d'électricité 15
mille foyers karina lazer pascal pouce
pour les sapeurs pompiers des bouches du
rhône c'est le pire scénario de départs
de feu simultanés dans un massif
difficile d'accès et un appui aérien
réduit et canadair sont interdits de vol
pour enquête depuis l'accident de lundi
là il n'ya pas d'avion or il ya du vin
et à la sécheresse et à tous pire tout
pourquoi
pour cobo revoilà et on gonfle incendie
s'est déclaré vers 15 heures près
d'aubagne 500 hommes ont été rapidement
mobilisés malgré l'intervention de
tracteurs et des hélicoptères
bombardiers d'eau
le feu a franchi la voie ferrée le
trafic sncf est interrompu entre
marseille et la ciotat
poussé par un mistral à 70 km/heure les
flammes progressent vers l'est
le village de carnoux est désormais en
première ligne on a sorti les tuyaux
tous branchés on a fermé des fenêtres
les volets voilà les mots heureusement
qu'on a débroussaillé
au printemps apparemment pour ce qui
concerne la protection mutisme en bonne
voie parce que le feu ici est plus ou
moins ralenti il nous reste des phase de
noyage à effectuer actuelle en a eu à
gérer de 2 peu différent un qui a menacé
la ville de la peine sur huveaune et
l'autre qui menaçaient toujours la ville
de cannes
actuellement le feu terrebonne est en
bonne voie mais les deux feux ne sont
toujours pas fixés par précaution un
village de vacances a été évacué le feu
a déjà ravagé une centaine d'hectares de
pinède et en ce moment les pompiers
redouble d'efforts pour essayer de
maîtriser un incendie avant la tombée de
la nuit
voilà c'était dans le secteur de bagnes
et puis une cérémonie s'est déroulée
aujourd'hui à l'aéroport de bastia en
hommage aux deux pilotes tués lundi dans
le crash de leur canadair le préfet de
corse a rappelé que ces hommes étaient
morts sans doute victime comportements
criminels à l'origine du feu qu'il
combattait les corps ont été rapatriés à
la base aérienne de marignane où se
dérouleront les obsèques demain matin à
10h au portugal la situation sur le
front des incendies est plus
préoccupante qu'en france plus de 1200
sapeurs pompiers luttent toujours pour
venir à bout d'une quinzaine de feux 52
mille hectares ont déjà brûlé le mois
dernier tout le pays est en alerte
puisqu'on prévoit des températures
dépassant les 40° dans les prochains
jours deux jours après l'accident de
l'airbus d'air france à toronto les
enquêteurs canadiens semblent mettre
hors de cause la procédure
d'atterrissage de l'appareil
il faudra quand même attendre l'étude
des boîtes noires pour en savoir plus
pour l'instant le pilote de l'avion n'a
pas pu être interrogé
il est toujours hospitalisé pour une
blessure au dos sur place pascal golomer
tristan le bras
ce n'est plus un avion c'est une longue
carcasse calcinée
l'airbus a340 d'air france est coincé au
fond d'un petit ravin à deux pas de
l'autoroute bien au delà de la piste
d'atterrissage où il était censé
s'arrêter
un vidéaste amateur a filmé ces images
lorsque l' incendie faisait rage
quelques minutes seulement après que les
passagers et l'équipage
kurt évacuer la place on imagine les
conséquences d'une évacuation mal
conduite
aujourd'hui les 35 enquêteurs canadiens
épaulés par leurs collègues français
examinent les restes de l'appareil
les roues les freins vont être
transférés pour une analyse approfondie
les enregistreurs de vol les fameuses
boîtes noires ont été retrouvées en
assez bonne et a paraît-il mais jean
cyril spinetta le patron d'air france
arrivé hier à toronto l'a pas attendu le
résultat des analyses pour commenter les
circonstances de l'accident
si le pilote a tenté l'atterrissage
malgré l'orage violent dutil c'est parce
que la tour de contrôle a jugé que ce
n'était pas risque d'aéroport n'a jamais
été fermé donc les autorités portuaires
par monte estimé que les conditions pour
atterrir et des difficiles mais restait
possible
alors qui est responsable de
l'atterrissage d'un avion
le ministre des transports canadien a
immédiatement envoyé la balle la seule
personne qui prend la décision
d'atterrir
c'est le pilote c'est le commandant et
par conséquent lui seul a la
responsabilité totale de cette
décision-là l'analyse des conversations
entre la tour de contrôle et le pilote
il faudra peut-être des réponses
le chef des enquêteurs en tout cas ne
veut surtout pas s'engager dans la
politique ça va que les conditions
météorologiques étaient un facteur
déterminant important est bien le bureau
prendra les décisions qui s'imposent
quant à l'émission de mesures de
correction mesures de sécurité pour
éliminer ou réduire ses dangers en clair
peut-être faudra-t-il redéfinir les
procédures d'atterrissage par mauvais
temps
mais l'enquêté ne fait que commencer
le pdg d'air france qui est toujours à
toronto annoncé que tous les rescapés
français recevront une indemnisation
totale pour les dommages qu'ils ont
subis des rescapés qui petit à petit
reprennent leur vie normale malgré un
sentiment de peur toujours très présents
caroline gauthier dominique bonnet
quatorze adolescents heureux de se
retrouver ensemble et jeunes français
sont venus pour un séjour linguistique
au canada
tout de suite après le crash ils ont
chacun été hébergé dans une famille
canadienne
ils ont été accueillis écouté par ses
parents certains plus ou moins choqué
que d'autres vous savez ils sont jeunes
ils ont 17 ans je pense que c'était
comme aller dans un parc d'attractions à
disneyland le plus grand choc ils l'ont
eue quand ils ont réalisé quand ils ont
vu tous les médias du monde entier
derrière leurs sourires des souvenirs
douloureux qu'il faut évacuer alors
aujourd'hui un psychologue arrivé de
paris va les entendre on travaille c'est
de repérer les ados qui sont
particulièrement en difficulté de les
recevoir de façon individuelle et de
décider avec eux ce qu'il est opportun
de faire et ce qu'il reste c'est ce qui
me continuer le le séjour ou est-ce
qu'il faut les rapatrier
j'ai rencontré l'autre personne à
quelques minutes nous et qui ne
souhaitait pas reprendre l'avion donc il
va falloir discuter avec elle pense que
que le psychologue à côté de moi va
pouvoir les aider éventuellement un
point où les accompagnera s'il faut s'il
souhaite qu'on soit avec eux on les
aidera nous les deux un propriétaire qui
était à l'instant dans l'avion avec eux
lors de l'accident et ving biseau de son
côté se sont bien seuls dans ce même
hôtel ses amis ont souhaité poursuivre
leur voyage mais son mari et blessé
trois côtes cassées un organe perforé il
est toujours à l'hôpital
j'attends mon mari et le pit a parce
qu'il m'a téléphoné ce matin c'était pas
très brillant j'attends de voir comment
il va pour pour pour envisager de partir
un peu plus de 24 heures après le crash
c'est maintenant que les rescapés
réalise vraiment ce qu'ils ont vécu des
images de panique qui leur reviennent et
qui leur ferait presque oublier qu'ils
sont des miraculés
pour les psychologues il s'agit de faire
leur diagnostic déterminer ceux pour qui
le retour en france est aujourd'hui
indispensable et en direct de toronto on
retrouve pascal golomer bonsoir pascal
on parle peu ce soir du pilote et de son
équipage
et pour cause ils sont vraiment tenu
éloigné de la presse pour les besoins de
l'enquêté
oui c'est en tout cas l'argument
qu'avance la direction d'air france pour
ne donner que très peu voire aucune
information sur les membres de cet
équipage dont les passagers nous ont
tant vanté les mérites depuis deux jours
ce qu'on est et ce qu'on sait en tout
cas c'est que jean cyril spinetta qui
est donc à toronto a pu rencontrer les
membres de l'équipage à l'exception du
pilote
le pilote qui est toujours hospitalisé
pour des blessures au dos semble-t-il
c'est la seule information dont on
dispose il n'a pas pu non plus répondre
aux questions des enquêteurs qui
attendent que les médecins donnent le
feu vert
en revanche le copilote lui devrait en
principe aujourd'hui répondre aux
questions de ses enquêteurs c'est lui
qui était aux commandes de l'appareil
mardi après midi c'est lui également qui
a fait le tour de l'avion après
l'évacuation des passagers pour vérifier
que personne était resté à l'intérieur
les stewards et les hôtesses
eux aussi devraient témoigner dans les
prochains jours les témoignages peut
être moins technique que les
informations que livreront les boîtes
noires mais qui pourrait donner des
indications sur ce qui s'est exactement
passé à bord de l'airbus d'air france
mardi après midi
merci beaucoup pascal après les
attentats de londres et celui de sharm
el cheikh en egypte le numéro deux d'al
qaïda est réapparu aujourd'hui dans une
vidéo diffusée par al jazeera al
zaouahri menace directement la grande
bretagne et les etats unis stephen
breitner le rang des bois pour cette
troisième vidéo depuis le début de
l'année la mise en scène est toujours la
même tenue impeccable barbe bien taillée
et fusils kalachnikov poser à sa droite
à ayman al zaouahri bras droit d'oussama
ben laden fait reparler d'al qaïda comme
dans cet enregistrement du mois de
février dernier
ses premiers mots sont pour les anglais
attentats du 7 juillet s'ils ne le
revendiquent pas directement
il met en garde la grande bretagne aux
anglais je leur dit blair vous a attiré
la destruction jusqu'au centre de
londres sa politique vous apportera
d'autres destructions
si dieu le veut bien évidemment celui
que l'on présente comme l'idéologue d'al
qaïda s'adresse également aux américains
et le message est toujours le même tout
ce que vous avez vécu à new york à
washington ainsi qu'en afghanistan et en
irak ne sont que les premières pertes
il n'y a pas d'autres portes de sortie
qu'un retrait immédiat de l'interdire à
tout report de cette décision signifie
davantage de morts et de père heyman al
zaouahri s'adresse enfin à son pays
d'origine l'egypte après les attentats
de sharm el cheikh il met en garde le
président moubarak qu'ils accusent
d'être à la botte des états unis et
d'israël
il y à dire vous avez peur je viens vous
faire tort davantage ses premiers
messages en fait c'est la logique de
terreur qui est propre à l'organisation
son intervention peut peut-être
remobiliser des cellules mais n'est pas
forcément indicatrices d'action qui
suivront forcément george bush a réagi
ce soir pour le président américain
ce message prouve que la guerre contre
le terrorisme ce livre en irak
une menace qui bien sûr augmente encore
un peu plus la crainte des londoniens
déjà très nerveux après les attentats du
7 et du 21 juillet dernier
comme chaque jeudi la sécurité
renforcées dans les transports en commun
plusieurs milliers de policiers étaient
déployés dans le bus et dans le métro
claude samper rail fanny plus de 6000
policiers dans les rues de londres une
des plus importantes mobilisations des
forces de l'ordre dans la ville depuis
la seconde guerre mondiale
hélicoptères patrouillent au sol très
visible dans les lieux touristiques gare
de renforcer devant tous les bâtiments
officiels comme ici le 10 downing street
les bureaux du premier ministre
et bien évidemment une protection à plus
près des bus et des stations de métro
nous sommes toujours un haut niveau d'
alerte car nous pensons qu'il ya
peut-être encore des terroristes qui
pourraient commettre de nouvelles
attaques et rendez vous l'après midi
toutes les chaînes d'information
britanniques ont retransmis la nouvelle
déclaration d'al zawahiri menaçant la
grande bretagne
aujourd'hui quatre semaines jour pour
jour après les premiers attentats
la ligne de métro pic à 10 a été
rétablie dans sa totalité dans cette
station 26 personnes avaient trouvé la
mort normalement je voyage tous les
jours à londres sans inquiétude mais là
c'est un peu différent quand vous
voyagez dans le métro vous êtes obligés
d'y penser
vous avez le sentiment que ça peut
recommencer à tout moment sur le plan
judiciaire
un premier homme de 23 ans a été
officiellement inculpé pour avoir aidé
les poseurs de bombes il reste à l'heure
actuelle 14e personne toujours interrogé
par la police
les nouvelles menaces du numéro deux
d'al qaïda n'ont provoqué aucune
réaction de la part de tony blair ou de
scotland yard
les britanniques n'ont pas vraiment
besoin de ce genre de cassettes vidéo
pour être convaincu que la menace
terroriste existe depuis les attentats
il s'efforce de reprendre une vie
normale tout en demeurant extrêmement
vigilant pas moins de 450 faux
passeports européens ont été retrouvés
lors d'un contrôle à l'aéroport de
bangkok en thaïlande ce type d'affaires
est courant dans ce pays accusé par
l'union européenne d'être au centre d'un
trafic de faux papiers
mathias hillion patrick desmulie la
saisie est impressionnante 450 de faux
passeports européens et parmi eux une
centaine de documents français falsifiés
l'homme arrêté hier à l'aéroport de
bangkok affirme n'être qu'un passeur ce
britannique d'origine algérienne dit
avoir reçu plus de 26 mille euros pour
ramener les documents falsifiés à
londres c'est là qu'il devait être
revendue
il y à des passeports portugais
espagnols belges français c'est l'un des
plus beaux coups de fil et de notre
service de l'immigration
l'homme s'apprêtait à quitter bangkok
direction amsterdam puis edimbourg quand
il a été arrêté
l'europe soupçonne la capitale
thaïlandaise d'héberger une industrie de
fabrication de faux papiers il y à des
ateliers avec des capacités de haute
technologie donc effectivement la ville
de bangkok à l'aéroport majeur en plus
pour l'asie est un endroit où beaucoup
de contrefaçons sont opérés notamment
celles d'autres documents d'identité
chacun de ces faux passeport est vendu
entre 2500 et 3000 euros le lot saisi
hier aurait donc pu rapporter plus d'un
million d'euros aux trafiquants à ce
stade de l'enquêté
aucun lien n'a été établi entre l'homme
arrêté à bangkok et un groupe terroriste
au moment où ariel sharon doit déjà
gérer la résistance de certains colons à
quelques jours du retrait de gaza
voici une affaire qui pourrait encore
alimenter la tension dans le pays
ce soir hamid rallier en tenue militaire
a tenu a tué trois personnes avant de se
faire lyncher à mort par la foule
cet incident s'est passé dans une ville
arabe israélienne dans le nord du pays
charles enderlin
selon les chaînes de télévision
israéliennes il s'agit bien d'un
attentat commis par un extrémiste juif
en fin d'après-midi à chf haram est une
ville arabe mixte musulmane et
chrétienne de galilée
un jeune israélien en uniforme et
militaire a ouvert le feu dans cet
autobus tuant le chauffeur et deux
femmes
il a été maîtrisé et lynché à mort par
la foule
le terroriste avait 19 ans déserteur de
l'armée il aurait habité une colonie
peuple et d'ultra proche de naplouse
la nouvelle de cette attaque a suscité
une profonde émotion au sein de la
population arabe d'israël
des appels à la vengeance se font
entendre
la police craint de violentes
manifestations en galilée dans les
prochaines heures et demain vendredi
jour de prière et l'on reparle de la
grippe aviaire ce virus qui touche les
volailles ne se limite plus seulement à
l'asie du sud est et à la chine depuis
quinze jours déjà les élevages de russie
sont également touchés par l'épidémie
ce virus peut se transmettre à l'homme
et les contaminations entre humains sont
rares pour l'instant reste que les
scientifiques se prépare à tous les
scénarii jean daniel flaysakier jacques
gérard à bord de ce vol de migrateurs
qui se pose près de novossibirsk en
sibérie
il ya un passager bien indésirables le
virus h5n1
le virus de la grippe aviaire ce germe
tant redouté a donc quitté l'asie du
sud-est pour s'inviter en russie les
autorités ont déjà dû sacrifier 65 mille
volailles pour juguler l'infection mais
tous les observateurs ont le regard fixé
sur la chine le vietnam et guettent avec
angoisse l'arrivée de l'automne
cette région du monde est une
gigantesque ferme à ciel ouvert où les
paysans cohabitent dans une incroyable
promiscuité avec les canards les valises
et les cochons le danger c'est que le
virus h5n1 et le virus humain se
rencontrent à un moment ou un autre
chez le porc par échange de matériel
génétique le virus aviaire pourrait
alors s'humaniser être capable
d'infecter des millions de personnes
face au spectre des pandémies comme
celle de 1918 la fameuse grippe
espagnole ou bien encore celle de 1957
les chercheurs réfléchissent à des
modèles de prévention oise
deux études publiées hier montrent que
le pire est évitable à certaines
conditions
si nous détectons les tout premiers cas
humains si nous leur donnons des
médicaments antiviraux ainsi que leur
entourage
ici on ferme les écoles et les usines on
peut imaginer stopper la propagation de
l'épidémie
il faudra être sûr de disposer d'une
quantité suffisante du seul médicament
efficace il faudra aussi que les pays
concernés signal très vite les premiers
cas suspects or par le passé la chine
n'a pas toujours joué le jeu c'est
pourtant à ce prix qu'on pourrait éviter
un drame sanitaire planétaire de plus
d'autant qu'aucun vaccin n'est
actuellement disponible en france le
conseil d'état donne raison aux
écologistes il a suspendu l'arrêté du
ministère qui autorisait dès samedi la
chasse de certains gibiers d'eau la
saison ne commencera que dans trois
semaines au grand damne des chasseurs
qui appellent déjà à se mobiliser
après demain christophe de vallans bras
julien delage trois semaines de sursis
au moins pour les canards et quelques
autres espèces de gibier d'eau
la ministre de l'ecologie nelly olin
voulait autoriser leur chasse dès ce
week end en référé le conseil d'état
elle en a empêchés selon lui les espèces
concernées sont protégés car toujours en
période de nidification ou de dépendance
des petits ce que constate aussi la
ligue protectrice des oiseaux dans cette
réserve de rochefort voilà comme on peut
le voir encore là sur le site on a
observé 26 chez et parmi ses nombreuses
nées chez il ya encore pratiquement 5
signifier qu'ils sont pas vraiment
puisque les hauts fourneaux la première
quinzaine de juillet mais les chasseurs
rétorque que leur zone de tir en bord de
mer est loin des sites de nidification
et que les oiseaux qui s'y aventurent
sont donc forcément en pleine capacité
d'être chassé les observations et les
arguments des chasseurs ont contribué à
en convaincre la ministre de l'écologie
mais pas le conseil d'état
rien n'est dit dans la directive oiseaux
sur la notion de dépendance des oiseaux
sur le fait qu'on puisse les chasser ou
pas les chasser donc après c'est une
question d'interprétation
lange en france la réglementation et les
tribunaux sont extrêmement sévères
envers là l'aspect cynégétique et nous
laisse peu de chances de faire aboutir
nos argumentation et c est regrettable
le conseil d'état a souligné que les
données sur lesquelles ses bases et le
ministère pour avancer l'ouverture de la
chasse ne sont pas fiables
pour les plaignants c'est une victoire
qui discrédite nelly olin ne savons très
bien que la ministre de l'écologie a été
nommée pour par pression des chasseurs
les chasseurs voulait quelqu'un qui leur
soit qu'ils soient pro chasse qui leur
soit plus favorable et la ministre c'est
en quelque sorte exécuté nelly olin a
pris acte de la décision du conseil
d'état et à repousser la chasse des
espèces concernées à la fin du mois
samedi de nombreux chasseurs devraient
manifester leur mécontentement
la sncf fait la chasse aux lignes
déficitaires un projet prévoit de
réduire la desserte de trois trains
corail de l'ouest de la france
des lignes qui ne seraient pas
suffisamment rentable faute de voyageurs
vous découvrez les trois trajets
concernés par ce projet il s'agit de
caen le mans tours également quimper
nantes bordeaux toulouse et pour finir
nantes lyon les régions bretagne et
basse-normandie monte au créneau et
parle d'atteinte aux services publics
reportage à nantes vincent fourcade
alexandra renard
le train corail de 14h39
il fait tous les jours un aller retour
entre nantes et quimper une lignes
interrégionales qui risque bien de
disparaître avant la fin de l'année
c'est drôlement pratique
regardez regardez le froid fille pesait
sur pendant les vacances et c'est
l'idéal pour nous serait certainement
poser des problème puisqu'on vient de la
région 100 de nos verres donc ça va nous
obliger à passer par paris
donc été gvt et réservation tarifs
supplémentaires double de chemin des
trains corail apprécié des voyageurs ils
sont pourtant de moins en moins nombreux
à y prendre place
la sncf souhaite donc réduire la voilure
sur trois de ses 25 lignes
inter-régionales trois lignes qui chaque
année lui font perdre plus de 20
millions d'euros sur notre région sur
les pays de loire nous avons un certain
nombre de trains qui sont déficitaires
la fréquentation est en moyenne de 150
voyageurs par jour il faudrait dans
certains cas quel faut le double voire
le triple pour que les trains soient
équilibrés moins de corail à l'horizon
dans neuf régions et ce sont les pays de
la loire qui devrait être le plus
durement touché 71 points en moins par
semaine
la région on a déjà perdu 29 l'an passé
diminution de l'offre de 65% par rapport
à ces trains corail qui traverse la
région des pays de la loire
dix mille voyageurs concernés chaque
semaine qui vont rester sur les quais
puisque lorsque ces trains ne
circuleront plus les voyageurs seront
sur les quais région et sncf n'ont plus
qu'un mois pour trouver une solution de
rechange et éviter la suppression de
trains interrégionaux
la bataille du rail est donc bien lancé
comme prévu ce matin à 8 heures les
premiers automobilistes ont pu emprunter
à nouveau le tunnel du fréjus après deux
mois de fermeture pas d'incident pour
cette première journée la circulation et
sans restriction pour les véhicules
légers en alternance pour les poids
lourds de plus de 3 tonnes 5 à cause du
mauvais temps huit alpinistes sont
restés bloqués pendant trois jours dans
le massif du mont blanc ils ont
finalement été retrouvé sain et sauf par
le peloton de gendarmerie de haute
montagne de chamonix
une unité qui vient au secours des
imprudents de jour comme de nuit
et contrairement aux idées reçues il ne
chôme pas durant l'été et mathias
hillion carole gréco la montagne est
encore plus dangereuse l'été que l'hiver
davantage de randonneurs et d'alpinisme
sur les sommets cela signifie davantage
d'interventions pour ces gendarmes en
altitude le moindre malaise est pris au
sérieux
l'hélicoptère est dépêchée en urgence
pour un jeune homme pris de panique au
sommet du mont maudit nous dépend du
temps à pleurer devant un peu peur
c'est pas très grave mais il faut qu'il
aille se
mais bon un petit peu dans pas longtemps
à l'hôpital mal aigu des montagnes
luxation fracturé le massif du mont
blanc ne pardonne aucune erreur
les vacances sportives peuvent
rapidement tourné court
on a chuté à 3 et donc on a des valeurs
peu près 50 60 m de pente glacée
ça va me sens mieux un gros stress
évidemment j'avais les cuisses qui qui
fonctionnait plus et qu'il s'en tienne à
tétaniser complètement et les publics je
suis vu leur groupe avec qui j'étais
petit on est encore à 4300 mètres selon
les professionnels de la haute montagne
beaucoup de ces accidents pourraient
être évités ce qu'on peut regretter
c'est que le mont blanc est un objectif
il n'y a pas de préparation en amont
lorsque les gens sont mal en altitude il
n'apprécie guère la montée et ça se
termine par un retour en hélicoptère un
manque de précaution parfois mortelles
un guide de haute montagne vient de
repérer un corps sans vie dans cette
zone
il a aussitôt prévenu les secours le
gendarme va alors chercher à déterminer
la cause du décès dans la plupart des
cas l'origine est accidentelle
il arrive aussi que des personnes se
suicident en sautant dans le vide
les premières constatations sont
importantes a scellé dès qu'on arrive à
ce sens à partir de cette base là qu'on
peut commencer à élaborer des recherches
savoir aussi bas il a glissé ou s'il
s'est jeté dans l'eau ou si il faisait
de l'escaladé qu'il ya une corde qui a
cassé ou un mousqueton
donc là mon collègue est en train de
voir s'ils trouvent quelque chose quoi
pour identifier la victime les gendarmes
recherchent ces papiers dispersés dans
la montagne lors de sa chute de plus de
300 mètres comme ses collègues jean marc
gales 1 a appris à vivre avec la mort
notre naissance au courant ce n'est pas
le ramassage de corps inerte
c'est jamais très beau ce que les coques
retrouve en montagne peut faire appel à
des psychologues aussi comment ça va pas
mais souvent on se fait notre thérapie
le matin au café ou entre nous entre
copains on en parle et puis on n'arrive
pas dit mystifié la chose comme ça en
juillet neuf personnes ont trouvé la
mort dans le massif du mont blanc
mais ces gendarmes de haute-montagne
préfère retenir le nombre de personnes
qui l'ont secourue 115 depuis le début
de l'été des statistiques en
augmentation par rapport à l'année
dernière
le quai d'orsay suit de très près la
sphère de ce français détenu depuis huit
jours au vietnam
il avait été contrôlé en possession de
médicaments interdits dans ce pays
son épouse et ses proches se mobilisent
pour mettre fin à son cauchemar dorothée
cochard benoît gadret 25 femmes
devraient être en train de vivre des
vacances de rêve au vietnam
il est retenu depuis huit jours par les
policiers sa faute
être en possession d'un grand nombre de
médicaments à base de morphine interdit
sur le sol vietnamien
depuis maintenant deux jours trois 3
jours il est
on secret personne ne peut le voir sa
famille il n'y a aucune nouvelle et
nous-mêmes attendant des nouvelles de
chant qui par ailleurs est malade
puisqu'il a des problèmes de dos
confirmation de son médecin
28 femme souffre du dos depuis des
années et souffre beaucoup plus par
plusieurs hématologue avec des
infiltrations infiltration arrêt maladie
de plusieurs mois son médecin pour son
départ a dû lui prescrit un grand nombre
de médicaments antidouleur à base de
morphine son erreur c'est de ne pas
avoir vérifié la liste des médicaments
autorisés au pas au vietnam et la
deuxième chose aussi c'est de ne pas
avoir emmené les ordonnances dans bay et
ça aurait évité je pense beaucoup de
malentendus wenchang femme va devoir
maintenant prouver sa bonne foi
les autorités vietnamiennes poursuivre
leur vérification des vérifications
d'autant plus rigoureuse que les
policiers vietnamiens ont été récemment
confronté à plusieurs affaires de trafic
de médicaments un trafic juteux estimé à
25 millions d'euros par an les jolies
colonies de vacances façon vladimir
poutine le gouvernement russe
subventionne des camps ouverts aux
enfants est destiné à développer leur
fibre patriotique
l'idée n'est pas nouvelle mais elle
séduit de plus en plus de jeunes russes
anne consignes et xavier luizet revue de
détail avant l'entraînement du matin ils
ont entre 10 et 17 ans et dans leurs
colonies de vacances
toutes les activités sont calquées sur
celles d'une caserne
bien sûr que j'ai décidé de vérifier mes
capacités pour voir si je peux bien tout
ça est ici c'est comme l'armée ça me
prépare au service militaire
les enfants manipulent des répliques de
kalachnikov
et s'il faut en croire les un scripteur
pour la plupart des réservistes
c'est ainsi qu'on fait des hommes
ce qu'on leur apprend à survivre dans
cette époque pas très paisible et rose
ont leur force de caractère la volonté
parce que le caractère on en a toujours
besoin
quant aux gamins bien sûr l'essentiel
pour eux c'est de jouer aux soldats il
n'y voit aucun mal
ici c'est pas comme à la guerre plus dur
c'est les punitions quand tu as fait
quelque chose de mal on t'envoie
éplucher les patates et la cuisine ont
creusé des trous créés du temps de
l'urss par des vétérans d'afghanistan
ce qu'on n'a pas toujours été aussi à la
mode il trouve un nouveau souffle et
plus de financements depuis que vladimir
poutine a lancé un programme d'éducation
patriotique
ce système des clubs patriotiques se
développe et les responsables nous
envoient leurs cadres en formation pour
profiter de notre expérience acquise au
but
la motivation des parents elle n'est pas
seulement patriotique ce qu'on ne coûte
pratiquement rien les services sociaux
offrent même des séjours gratuits à la
maison qu'est ce qu'il va faire - ici il
est surveillé histoire donc de renforcer
l'élan patriotique national le
gouvernement russe il ya tout juste
d'attribuer à ce genre de programme plus
de 13 millions de dollars en primes
il doit doit être votée instaurant une
formation militaire obligatoire au lycée
ceux là n'ont fait que prendre un peu
d'avancé
nouvelle illustration du réchauffement
de la planète et des océans une étude
publiée aujourd'hui montre l'importance
de la fonte des glaces depuis dix ans
des pans entiers se sont effondrés en
arctique
il y a deux ans du jamais vu depuis dix
mille ans benoît fait blé joseph
bastille qu on la croyait éternelle avec
ses falaises de plus de 200 mètres de
haut c'est larsen b
la banquise situé le long de la
péninsule antarctique elle est restée
intacte pendant dix mille ans larsen
suscite l'inquiétude des scientifiques
car en moins de dix ans une partie de la
plate forme glaciaire a subi deux gros
effondrements
sur cette première photographie la
banquise est entière
puis elle se disloque se désagrège a
même échelle le plus gros morceau fait
la moitié du morbihan le reste part à la
dérive et font les scientifiques en sont
sûrs c'est encore le réchauffement de la
planète qui est à l'origine de ces
événements
l'étude récente vient de montrer à
travers cette fois des forages dans les
sédiments marins que la plateforme de
larsen a été constamment présente dans
cette région tout au cours depuis dix
mille ans donc ça montre bien que ces
événements sont des disons
caractéristiques de la période récente
ça nous renforce dans l'idée aussi que
ce réchauffement est bien lié à l'action
de l'homme à l'augmentation de l'effet
de serre la banquise larsen n'est pas la
seule à s'effondrer
en avril dernier c'est l'iceberg b15 à
qui s'était détaché du plateau de roches
il menaçait de famille d'une colonie de
pingouins en leur bloquant l'accès à la
mer si vous ne cherchez pas le soleil à
tout prix vous pouvez essayer la
spéléologie dans l'autre ce sport
s'ouvre au grand public
là bas les gouffres et les grottes sont
spectaculaires mais très sécurisé visite
de l'un de ces sites qui sera
prochainement classée au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
julien moment nathalie gallet et au
milieu coule une rivière
nous sommes à 200 mètres sous le sommet
de la montagne dans le gouffre de
cabrespine l'un des plus grands de
france
cette source s'est infiltrée il ya
plusieurs millions d'années une source
acide qui a creusé la roche les sens ça
et là ou bien de l'érosion aragonite
colonnes et christ
la plupart des cristallisations que l'on
retrouve dans les grottes au maximum
5000 ans alors si on voit quasiment les
facettes des cristaux c'est eux qui
rendra notre lumière qui donne ce
scintillement c'est un effet miroir
super moche ça vraiment des manquants je
pensais pas que ça pouvait hésiter sur
terre
car en ces termes en mettant le pied
droit en bout pub à un paysage qui se
mérite et ubs nous sommes glissés voit
cinq heures de balade dans une eau à 10
degrés attention aux pièges degré n'est
pas la fin des embûches visite il
rappelle les principes de base de la
spéléologie singulière il est impossible
d'en sortir avec une randonnée ouverte à
tous à condition d'être en forme
bon alors madame c'était comment c'était
à 10 ans a grimpé la remontée réchauffe
je peux sans un autre milieu verts sont
vraiment comme si le temps était
suspendu comme dans un roman de jules
verne chemin parcouru à peine deux
kilomètres sur les 23 que compte le
gouffre il reste même encore des zones
inexplorées un mot de football pour vous
dire que marseille s'est qualifié pour
la finale de la coupe intertoto battant
la lazio rome au stade vélodrome ils ont
cloué le match en marquant trois buts en
seconde mi-temps en seulement cinq
minutes score final 3 à 0
à noter également la victoire de lens
face à l'équipe allemande de wolfsburg 4
à 0 sans appel à deux jours du
championnat du monde d'athlétisme la
majorité de l'équipe de france est déjà
arrivé à helsinki la france vise cinq
médailles mais pour l'instant le moment
est plutôt à la découverte des
infrastructures et de la ville sur place
manuel tisser liane moines
c'est un petit pays pour une immense
compétition un demi million de
finlandais accueille le troisième
événement sportif mondial elle sim qui
aime l'athlétisme les avenues bien
larges et sa tranquillité
mais les lacs de la région sont un petit
peu moins calme ces jours ci pendant
neuf jours
helsinki est un lieu sensible comme
londres paris ou madrid
dans le village des athlètes sous haute
protection les français prennent leurs
marques depuis hier le campus et coquet
verdoyant et les petites chambres
d'étudiants permettent de réunir les
générations ça bedia capitaine des bleus
transmet son expérience et ses souvenirs
à sa jeune coéquipière souvent aux
championnats du monde
l'hôtel est là ça change puisque c'est
le village on compte trois m'ont tout le
monde c'est une autre ambiance et un
petit peu comme les jeux quoi comme aux
jeux les stars de la piste
3 les jeunes pousses de l'athlétisme
maurice greene et les américains à
l'entraînement c'est toujours un
spectacle fascinant
on s'est fait un peu partie des grands
mais on arrive tout doucement on arrive
doucement on apprend la grande christine
arron entamera dimanche les séries du
100 m ce matin elle a subi aux aurores
un contrôle antidopage sans perdre sa
bonne humeur
c'est fait maintenant j'espère que d'ici
d'isimat quoi si on veut laisser dormir
à ce clown chérie tu perds le stade
olympique d'helsinki accueillera une
délégation française aux ambitions
mesurées objectif entre trois et cinq
podiums avec une bonne chance de
médaille dès ce week end
younis barber tentera de décrocher l'or
à l'heptathlon
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous de m'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météo isabelle martinez suivi le point
route julien pascal
20h55 dans le magazine on vous dit
pourquoi jérôme bonaldi avec lanciné may
et partent à la conquête de la lune
12h50 le journal vous sera présentée par
un homme était et on se quitte sur ces
images de la coupe du monde de kitesurf
qui s'est tenue aujourd'hui aux canaries
cette discipline permet de retrouver les
joies du cerf-volant tout en surfant
soleil levant et surtout bonne humeur
était au rendez vous je vous retrouve
lundi à 20h et celle en soirée bon
week-end sur france 2